all right man what's going on
no not too much how are you guys doing
we're doing awesome thank you for
hanging in there with us we got it
figured out let us just get a four just
hold the four up to start the fourth
quarter
all right we're gonna move through this
jeff lewis is coming on in a few minutes
but there's no way we're doing this show
without will the wizard on friday uh
telling us what's going on on
chainmetrics john already brought it up
sopra first chart what's going on here
yeah last week you know we we we're
looking at this bounce um when you look
at this little blue circle uh shaded
circle that i that i put in there that's
where we were at last week and so we
were looking for do we start to get
continuation uh to the upside in the
ratio and we have in fact as you see
on the right hand side of the chart so
this kind of resembles if you look back
to like september of last year
we had this 20 plus
percent correction and then we came back
down retested that one threshold and
then
started moving up from there so um
want to see that ideally but you know at
a minimum
you want to see that one threshold you
know hold obviously and maybe
stabilize above one
but yeah i mean i ideally we we continue
higher what you don't want to see
obviously is for us to go below and then
retest it and it becomes resistance but
for now looking really good
awesome expl exchange supply shock ratio
uh maybe not as bullish as it's been but
still not bearish either is my read
yeah so
we have three different things here um
the one that the one that's slightly
bearish is the highly liquid ratio so
this is looking at the movement of uh
coins from the highly liquid entities uh
to liquid entities so
the the ratio ticking down which means
coins are moving to the highly liquid
amenities
i think you're starting to get some of
this reflecting in price um i'm actually
kind of short-term i wouldn't say like
short-term perish but um i'm a little
cautious over the next two days i think
we probably come down and like recess
like 53k
um partially because of this also
exchange flows are just flat over the
last two weeks they're down like 490 btc
which um of course like isn't bearish to
say it's just not you know strongly
bullish so it's just neutral um and then
like when you look at the derivatives uh
funding
um so you look at the perpetual swap
funding we've had a really big spike
over the last like 24 hours and so to me
you know what that shows is like
traders are basically trying to trying
to leverage long the dip
and then oftentimes like when you see
funding go in the opposite direction of
price it usually resolves in the
direction of price so like
one example would be when we came off
that failed breakdown of 30k
um i remember
we did it we did one of these and i was
saying that we were set up for uh
favorable conditions for short squeeze
and the reason was was the same kind of
setup but the opposite so you had
funding
going more negative as price was going
up in open interest relative to market
cap was going up so in other words you
had people piling on shorts as price was
going the opposite direction
and that resolves of course we had this
massive i remember at the time it was a
huge move um
to like uh like mid or upper upper 40ks
um off off those lows so
i don't think we're gonna have a move of
that magnitude but i'm just saying it's
um you know when you when you start to
see that's just a good example when you
start to see funding go in the opposite
direction of price especially as open
interest is increasing as a proportion
to market cap
you're susceptible to these moves that
oftentimes resolve in the direction of
price so
i think you have some some late shorts
that hopped in and over the last 24
hours i mean you look at like some of
the aprs on on funding uh like i'll pull
it up right here
you know we're looking at like on some
exchanges up to like 67 percent apr like
on buybit for example
which often times by bits wrong
while at the same time ftx is much lower
at like 20 percent um
and derivatives there was at 38 so like
overall the you know funding funding is
uh
seen a big spike over the last 24 hours
so i don't know i'm kind of short-term
cautious obviously like long-term
picture hasn't changed at all but just
to you know for hodlers like who cares
right but i'm just saying you know just
just be wary if we start to trend down
over the next couple days um come back
down and re-test that 53k area um and
even as low as that that re-testing the
break above the point of breakdown from
may at 50k i don't think that's out of
the cards but um
i think like that 53k is probably a
logical area that's also like the
trillion dollar market cap area too so i
just think there's a couple different
things that confluence that that kind of
point to that being a nice little area
to maybe scoop up some btc over the next
couple days uh but yeah
let's get ahead to the supply shock
ratios i saw you tweet this out earlier
this week and this chart to me seems
like one of the most important charts
right now uh in all of bitcoin where
you've got kind of the historical uh
supply shock and you've outlined in this
like green bar uh talk to me a little
bit about like what this chart is really
highlighting and then once we kind of go
through it the way that we have what
does that mean for kind of future price
movements
sure so
what you see is heading into the bull
market and the long-term guys begin to
sell into strength heading into i should
say into strength and then heading into
weakness um the long-term guys begin to
accumulate heavily so conversely the
short-term guys
increasingly hold a larger portion of
supply into strength and then they move
out of the market into weakness the
speculators all leave
and so what you see here is
we're comparing the long-term holder
supply to short-term holder supply to
get the long-term holder supply shock
ratio
and what you see is just this is
illustrating the concept that when
long-term holders lock up a certain
portion of supply then you get the
supply squeeze effect on the market
long-term holders basically set the
floor um in a macro sense
and so we've actually reached an
all-time high in this metric so if you
look at the little circled area in the
top right you see where we're at
all-time highs and so what this is
showing is just
these long-term guys are locking up a
large portion of supply and you're
starting to get that effect on the
market that supply squeeze effect on the
market um one other thing i find
interesting about this though is like
as we've talked about many times we use
a five-month threshold for this so
155-day threshold for this
when you go back five months ago well
where were we well five months ago is
may 8th right and so
that was 11 days before we had this
initial barge drawdown to 30k
so to me that that's that's pretty
interesting right because you you're
you're seeing that these people are now
aging into long-term holders that held
the whole way down
um and so to me that that's that's
pretty remarkable it's it's showing that
perhaps um
you know these market participants are
having have a longer term uh time
horizon
got it and then let's go and look at the
bitcoin miners themselves you've got two
different charts uh one is just the
miners then one is the minor net
position change let's start with the
miners chart what is this showing us and
then kind of what is your view in terms
of uh what it's really telling us
yeah so the first chart with the three
different colors um orange that's hash
rate and then uh the blue line is
difficulty and then the green line is
minor balances so what you're seeing is
that hash continues to come back online
you know pretty aggressively and it's
come back online so aggressively that
we've had six positive uh difficulty
adjustments in a row which i don't even
know the last time that that's happened
it's just you know it's just another way
of kind of showing the same thing
and then also miners have started
accumulating a bit after selling into
into that rally off of the off of the
30k lows they did sell a bit um but now
they're slowly uh buying some more
nothing nothing substantial but you know
they are now back in a positive trend of
accumulation and that's reflected in
that um minor net position change metric
uh this is just looking at the 30-day
change of minor balances so you can see
we just started creeping back into that
green area and that that that's the
second chart up with the uh you know
highlighted with that little blue circle
so um yeah that that's what's going on
with miners also like at the bottom
you'll see the hash ribbon this is
another really interesting metric um
this is like probably
one of the best uh macro buy signals you
could say um in bitcoin um when you pair
this with um
when you pair this with like moving
averages for price it's been it's it's
never been wrong actually
and so what you're trying to capture
here is like
the
you're looking for these minor
capitulation events and then where hash
rate starts coming back online um and so
from first principles you're just
basically saying like for example in
2018 you had this large minor
capitulation once miners are done puking
out uh their coins then you can start
moving higher
and so we've got this hash ribbon buy
signal about a month ago a month and a
half ago
so that that means that the 30-day
the the 30-day moving average of hash
rate is crossing the 60-day moving
average of hash rate while at the same
time the 10-day moving average of price
is crossing the 20-day moving average
price um and so yeah like
when you when you look at this um when
you go when you go from white to light
red that means that the 30 day is
crossing the 60 day moving average when
you go from light red to red you're
going from um you where you're going
below and then when you go from light
red to red you're crossing above the 60
day and then the red to white is when
the when the 30 day crosses the 60 day
to the upside and also you have the the
10 day crossing to 20 days
so we zoom out
what's your take middle of the bull
market still super bullish over kind of
the medium term kind of next 90 days or
so uh or has your thoughts changed
no yeah um yeah still still standing on
my thesis over the next couple months
like i said i think perhaps we get a bit
of a pullback because some of the things
we talked about funding spiking exchange
flows are neutral and they had been
strongly bolstered over the last month
or so so
seeing like kind of a cooling off there
um some coins becoming highly liquid and
then lastly we're actually seeing a bit
of uh selling from whales or profit
taking from wales
which i don't think is like you know
complete red flag you know you're gonna
you're gonna see these active managers
um you know uh taking profits along the
way like the when you know when you zoom
out if you wanna pull that chart up for
the audience uh i think it's like the
third or fourth chart um
you'll see like
the the broader trend is still that
they've been an accumulation and yes
they trimmed a bit too as well in early
august so it's it's not
anything that um it's like a red flag
like bull market's over but i just think
perhaps we're gonna have a bit of a
drawdown to maybe like 53k um but i
don't know man like the market hasn't
been given anybody dips so we'll see
what happens but
for those reasons um i would just say
like i'm short-term cautious not
necessarily like short-term perish but
uh long-term you know that that outlook
hasn't changed
so my uh my last question for you is one
of the metrics that i'm gonna use uh to
know that uh things are getting crazy is
when your friends start asking you about
bitcoin that normally wouldn't are you
still uh got a lot of friends who they
have no clue what you do they're not
asking anything or has that started to
happen yet with the price going up a
little bit
no not at all um not not more than usual
uh like ten some of my buddies tend to
be a bit more uh
you know nerdy like me because then you
know we like geek out about stuff about
like bitcoin or whatever but um
so i don't know i
when i when i see people in general um
like people like uh that i haven't seen
in a while like everyone's always like
you know oh i see you're doing stuff
with bitcoin like what's up with that
but um i haven't seen any like i haven't
got any like tax like oh is it a good
time to buy bitcoin or anything like
that um i think like this stuff too is
reflected in like google search trends
um i think the block has some good like
retail related data um so you look at
google search trends also like um
coinbase app downloads is another way to
look at it um also you can look at the
large twitter accounts
um the large youtube accounts like some
of these things
but the google search trends is
primarily i think that and the coinbase
app downloads are probably two of the
better metrics for that and those are
both still way down
and then also you look at like
you can separate volume into you say
okay you know
how what size transactions are
dominating excuse me are dominating
volumes on each given day
and so what you see is over the last
month and a half really large
transactions have completely dominated
volume like we're talking like 10
million plus transactions have gotten up
to like 80 percent of all the volume on
any given day over the last month and a
half so that's just another way to look
at right now the the institutional
capital i think the smarter money i you
could say i think is is um more so in
the market and i i don't think we've
we've seen uh retail come in full force
yet awesome all right we got a whole
bunch of [ __ ] we still got to go through
on the show will you're a legend will
the wizard
please if you haven't already go follow
him on twitter where you cross over 300
000 followers now on his way to a
million uh oh no we'll pass me yeah
well
congratulations will and all your
success so far
that's the real flipping
congrats man that's awesome awesome
appreciate you guys all right we'll talk
soon all right thanks so much all right
see you guys